foreign
described we had Bobby in the script as
a cross between David Bowie and a
hairless cat is so strangely accurate if
you asked me to pick a role for myself
it would be weird Barbie Hi how are you
well weird Barbie was true truly the
Barbie you play with too much you brush
out her hair and then you decide you
want to cut it and then you see what
happens if you light it on fire and you
draw all over her face you put her in
the splits and try to change her clothes
I had this idea of like well we have to
have a Barbie that represents that fate
of so many Barbies and I wanted her to
be funny and wise Kate McKinnon was the
first person I thought of we've actually
known each other since we were 17 or 18.
I went to college with Greta and we were
in a playwriting class together I was
like
okay get ready to go someone told me
that she was wearing the Barbie movie I
was like Greta is making the Barbie
movie perfect I have to be part of it
what can I do you for I always thought
she was the most talented person I ever
met it was really special when we were
on set together it was a very full
circle moment so you can go back to your
regular life or you can know the truth
about the universe
the first one no
we'll do a redo we developed it sort of
together I mean she had a very strong
idea of like she knew what a weird
Barbie was yes she is like a shaman
figure the keeper of everyone's hidden
weirdness of Barbies put together a
Barbie is perfect and weird Barbie is
the one who's allowed to be asymmetrical
messed up and what we all have inside of
us is externalized in this piece of art
and then you look like me
I set myself up for that so we looked at
all of documents and documentations
everywhere of examples of real Barbies
being mutilated by different kids and
then of course the real discussions of
how we wanted to represent all those
looks in Kate McKinnon's character we
remade about four different wigs to try
and find the perfect look so it's taken
us a long time and we came up with two
very strong looks for her because she
kind of develops as The Story Goes On
[Music]
[Applause]